a new report claiming sexual harassment
and verbal abuse were common in the
front office of Washington's NFL
franchise The Washington Post found 15
women making allegations against
executives on that team the news follows
a decision to retire the team's
controversial nickname
Nikole Killion is at FedEx Field that's
the team stadium over in Landover
Maryland Nikol good morning how long do
these women say the harassment has been
going on or had gone on Tony these women
as say the allegations spanned from 2006
to 21
the organization one woman coming
forward is Emily Applegate a former
marketing coordinator who says she was
berated by her boss so often it brought
her to tears it really took most people
no time to comment on my appearance
Emily Applegate is one of 15 women who
spoke to the Washington Post
describing a culture of sexual
harassment and verbal abuse by former
members of the Washington NFL team's
front office I was so embarrassed that I
was being treated that way in front of
people you know like if you're getting
called stupid so many times in front of
somebody like that's really embarrassing
5x employees including some who were
part of owner Dan Snyder's inner circle
are accused of inappropriate language
and unwanted sexual advances in one
instance according to the post a female
staffer allegedly received a text
message from Richard man the former
assistant head of pro personnel asking
if her breasts were real or fake he
allegedly told the same employee I want
to squeeze your butt sexual harassment
is just been commonplace in that in that
office for upwards of 10 or 15 years
reporter will Hobson broke the story
they are subjected unwanted overtures
inappropriate remarks about you know
certain body parts and then also that
and a sales staff women have been
encouraged to dress low-cut blouses
tight skirts and one of the officials
named veteran play-by-play announcer
Larry Michael retired this week he was
actually caught on a hot mic speaking in
a
sexual manner about college-age intern
another personnel executive facing
allegations
Alex Santos was dismissed six former
employees and to reporters allege he
commented on their bodies and asked if
they were romantically interested in him
in a statement to the post the team said
it takes issues of employee conduct
seriously it has also retained a
prominent DC law firm to conduct a
thorough independent review and help the
team set new employee standards for the
future what does this mean for Dan
Snyder and his organization this
football team is at a crossroads right
now there certainly are a lot of women
who are skeptical that the culture can
truly change as long as here on owner
Dan Snyder has not been accused of
inappropriate behavior head coach Ron
Rivera told ESPN that he will not allow
such behavior and the team is working to
create a new culture we did reach out to
some of the former personnel named by
the accusers but have not heard back the
NFL however is speaking this morning
saying the allegations are contrary to
its values and pledged to take action
when the team's investigation is over
Gail well they've got a new coach who
makes it clear he will not tolerate that
kind of behavior that's very disturbing
thank you very much Nicole